you know the the fans out there are
nervous because they feel like season
four could be it for succession
maybe i don't know i have no idea i i
think they go season by season i know
they went in the writers room a couple
of weeks ago
uh if i were to guess
my guess they probably don't know
themselves so i don't know it's so
delicious yeah there's no way you can
stop after season before as as a fan of
the show i would like to see more i
would like to see at least two more
seasons yeah that's just as a fan okay
but i also trust jesse and if he feels
it's time to stop he's gonna be right
you turn 40 in september what does that
celebration look like for you oh
a usual day much like my 39th birthday
which was just changing diapers and you
know looking after kids and doing
nothing i have this idea
of like getting a cabin somewhere and
look like my wife and kids but then i
started thinking about the practicality
of like bringing the travel crib and the
two different kinds of diapers and the
whole thing just to like spend a weekend
because i'm 40 who cares
just stay home watch tv did you sit your
brother down and say and have a welcome
to the dad club moment with him no no no
he was racing there and it's like anyone
else like before a good friend of mine
had kids before me and his advice two
pieces of advice were
don't take anyone's advice and don't
worry you'll figure it out i'm like
that's the best advice to give anyone is
basically leave them alone it's there's
nothing you can do to really help just
you're in the pit enjoy it it's hard
it's the best is the second one for you
is it like madness or or after the first
do you kind of settle into kind of the
second one actually so because but
you people have different opinions but
that same friend had two kids and he
said
having two kids is not twice as hard
it's exponentially way harder but then
there's a lot of parents that say
actually
the first go around it because it
changes your life completely it took me
a whole year to really wrap my head
around okay things are completely
different yeah so by the time kid number
two it's just like okay well now there's
two of them right life is different life
is like people watch movies i had a
friend the other day said you know you
should meditate and i just was like
i don't have time
i can't even watch movies i'm looking
i'm hearing all these movies this year
great i haven't seen any of them